He should sue her into oblivion. Um, but he also made some
>> Oh, no, Techi. Oh, no. You going to defend your queen,
Techi? Hey, Techi, he just called Emiru a lying You going to
do anything about it? You going to just let that one slide? You
going to be a about this? This is a real misogynist who really
hates women.
>> Damn, bro.
Uh, TechTone admiring gains.
This combo could be really funny, like unironically. We call
the liberals and the and the women and the black people and all
sorts of [__] You call the
Oh, yeah, dude, all the time.
Really? We call out the Bro, we call out the violence, we call
out the You know, champion out, we call out the stupidity, like,
you know what I mean? The stupidity music, all that [__]
>> You don't call out the blacks, you call out the Yeah,
the morons. Yeah, the moronic ones, of course. Yeah, Dude, no
way.
TechTone trying to bait Myron into saying the hard R on a stream?
Let's go. >> You don't call out the blacks, you call out
the That's 100% what he's going for there. He was like, "Hey,
I can't say it, but you can say it. Call them the word, Myron.
Call them the word right now. Call them the word right now. If
If TechTone wasn't microtone, I believe Myron would listen. I
believe Myron would just immediately go and say the word, but
unfortunately,
Myron's heard the rumors and he's not interested now, okay? >> Yeah,
the morons. Yeah, the moronic ones, of course. Yeah, the the
N's, yes. Yes. Yeah, the Is that all right? Yeah.
>> You know what I mean? The for sure. You know, I I I
used to have this buddy who I would uh have come on my stream
just to say the N for me whenever I Whenever I I get
Yeah, that's way back in the day. >> Yeah, no, like And
And that's the thing, bro, like, you know, like, cuz my family's
from Sudan, right? I grew up in a Muslim household and [__]
like that, and I I'm consider myself black. But like, if people
do dumb [__] I will call it out whether I'm a part
of that tribe or not. You know what I mean? Like I'm very I try
to keep it real with whatever it is. So, I try to be honest about
that. But like yeah, other people they can't do that. For some
odd reason I find people a lot of people are not able to criticize
a group if they're like aligned with that >> Mhm. Yeah,
now I'm I'm 22% black so I try to keep my boys under control
and uh Oh, yeah? Yeah, yeah, you know [laughter] you know But
yeah,
you wanted to talk about the view biting thing with Extra Emily.
This view biting problem is is not good, and um you know, I hope
the the platforms will I crack down on it cuz it's everybody
up. I'm glad I'm glad that that's what you said and a pardon.
You're going to see my jaw freak the [__] out. I'm
I'm not a I don't have Tourette's. I just got into a fight when
I was a kid and my jaw's been [__] up ever since.
I beat the [__] out of the other guy. Like that guy
is much worse off than me. But anyway, just a little bit of I'm
I'm still waking up so my jaw goes crazy sometimes. Uh but I'm
glad that you said that the the platform needs to crack down
on it because that really is >> from his his His dad hit
him in the face. His dad hit him. That was his dad [__]
up his jaw. We pretty much took down the channel called Fextralife
about four or five years ago. They were kind of like the biggest
notorious botter that everybody knew was botting but nobody knew
how to do anything about it. So, Asmongold actually developed
a program with help of other people to auto detect the amount
of legitimate viewers on this channel because Fextralife was
a user that had 30 viewers that was botting 45,000.
Oh, wow. >> Yeah, ridiculous. 45,000 [laughter] viewers
every single time they went live. Um that's kind of when um everybody
started realizing, "Oh, [__] So, everything Tectone
and Asmongold were saying Did Myron get hair plugs or something?
Yeah, a long time ago. He had like really bad hair replacement
like maybe two years ago.
Where it's like very obvious. There's a There's the back view
cam on Fresh and
that would pick up you could see like the line. From this angle
it looks bad. From the back you can see the line where his old
hairline is like still fading and the new hairline is just like
stark against it. It's rough. thing is true. View botting is
a massive issue on Twitch. There was another streamer called
Reckful who actually called out another streamer called um I
believe his name was Misant SC. He was a big Hearthstone streamer
um and he was botting around 3 to 4,000, but people always deemed
Reckful crazy. Uh but you know, it it's crazy where we've gone
from if you say someone's view botting, you're a deranged paranoid
schizophrenic to now when you say they're view botting, it's
like, "Oh, yeah." Because everybody is and everybody always has
been. Who's Who's been called a deranged Hands up, guys, if you
been called a deranged paranoid schizophrenic before? Hands up,
who's been called a deranged paranoid schizophrenic? Oh, it's
Tech Done. Oh, it's Tech >> other streamer called Mizkif
where OTK had an it had a they had to have an intervention because
um he was botting 14,000 people and he didn't know like no he
wasn't telling anybody. So, OTK would run events on his channel
because they assumed
that uh she was the biggest streamer because he would bot 14K
so consistently.
Um and then once they found that out because some DMs of his
leaked with um the person who you know helps him run his channel.
Everybody chewed him the [__] out for essentially
the death of OTK, which is very ironic because people say, "Oh,
without Mizkif, OTK would be nothing." But it's not true because
these other streamers were funneling their viewers
I'm just sorry.
>> Mizkif was obviously certainly in that Austin scene
until Sodapoppin showed up there. Mizkif was obviously the most
entertaining streamer in that house. I I like it's just Dude,
just watch the
Just watch any of the content. Mizkif was obviously the most
entertaining person there.
Like I I understand thinking Miz is or that he's like narcissistic.
I understand like so many different views on Miz, but he was
obviously
the most entertaining streamer there.
It's not even close.
Miz is so trash. He was Dude, you
you don't have the sight. You can't see it. You can't see it.
This is entertaining. This is funny.
And also a lot of the other guys were not at all, okay? Sorry.
>> who had illegitimate an illegitimate fan base. And Miss
gives it all budding 4,000 viewers on Kick till today. And he's
outwardly public about it, which is
>> Yeah, I um I I was talking about that yesterday. Um
yeah, see I didn't even know who this guy was. Um I saw the the
controversy with the girl that gave the false allegation, which
is, you know, and she should He should sue her into oblivion.
Um but he also made some
>> Oh, no, Tackie. Oh, no, you going to defend your queen,
Tackie? Hey, Tackie, he just called Emiru a lying You going to
do anything about it? You going to let that one slide? You going
to be a about this? Oh,
I bet you nobody's even watched this content yet. Nobody clipped
this content. He probably thinks he got away with this. That
he just lets it slide. If he does, if he lets it slide on Emmy,
nah, buddy, nah, this [__] is getting clipped now.
>> comments cuz like when me, Tate, and Nick Fuentes were
all at and Sneako were all at the club uh with Clavicular, like
he made some stupid-ass comments like, "Oh, these guys are Nazis."
or some other [__] like that. And it's like, "Bro,
shut the [__] up, man. Like you're you're super sus.
You're a weirdo. Um like a lot of Twitch streamers are just like
stupid, man. Like it's like oh Oh, Tackie, you didn't defend
the queen, Tackie. Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
That's crazy to have a flexible spine like that. Who lets that
[__] go? That was uh That was not so erudite coded.
And funny enough, it was Myron both times calling the woman a
gold-digging,
And then supposedly their friend sitting there and just being
like
Myron, man, exposing people for a total lack of spine all over
the internet. Oh, you can't say anything controversial. Oh, no.
And I have my whole problem with Twitch. I'm like permanently
banned on there for like hate speech. >> You're permanently
banned on Twitch?
Yeah, permabanned, yeah. Okay, we got to do this part. What did
you say? Can you Can you We'll We'll zoom through this.
Like Like it's it's crazy everything, right? Like I said, right?
He'll talk about Israel. He'll talk about whatever, right? But
he's a progressive. Progressives get away with talking [__]
about Israel and the Jews or whatever cuz they kind of do it
from a different way. Like they do it
Uh Hasan doesn't say the same things Myron says. It's very different
when Myron says it. Like Hasan is talking about Israel and he
tries to differentiate and there's at least that effort that
they can point
Myron's like, "No, there There's no >> moral humanitarian
perspective. Whereas like I just call it what it is. They run
America and they have too much goddamn power and they use it
for their own benefit, right? Like dragging us in this war with
Iran right now. Like I saw someone in your chat say Myron's wrong
about the Middle East. No, you're You don't know anything about
the Middle East. You're probably
The reality is is that like most Americans don't understand Middle
Eastern foreign policy because
Dude, I It's just It's crazy the like
once you get to a certain point, it's crazy that
you'll just ask people. It's like the second they criticize you.
Why you mad about what I'm saying? You It's You Myron does that
instinctively like instantly.
And somehow
the media in America. >> Like never mind. Whenever I say
this, some people are like, "Oh, dude. No." And it's like, "No,
dude. Like it's literally true." Like if you When you go ahead
and you start unraveling the yarn, you'll figure out who's pulling
all the strings. But yeah, anyway, long story short, that's why
I ended up happening. I got banned on Twitch for being critical
of Israel in power. And the only way you can do that without
getting banned is by being a progressive because they kind of
come at it from a different perspective. They come at it from
[clears throat] the genocide humanitarian perspective. Whereas
like Yeah, I come at it from that perspective, too, but we also
have like a very serious problem of subversion in our country
from, you know, from these Zionists. Just because I'm I would
I I I have to tell you this for for your own well-being and for
my own mental sanity. Um Sure. >> I I would never worry
about a single thing that Mizkif says about anything or anyone
ever again because he has no collective he has no original viewpoints
of his own. He's just the guy who says what people think. Uh
he says the things that he knows people want him to say. So regardless
whatever he says he's just
He's a toddler, bro. He's a toddler who blew up. He has no life
experience. There's no way there's Dude.
Okay, hello mirror posting? Mirror posting? Totally just mirror
posting? Maximum mirror posting?
Totally shameless.
Mirror posting. What What in the hell, man? So he's just He's
The reason why he blew up is because he Do you know who Reckful
is?
No. Who's that? Oh, [clears throat] right right right right right
right. Okay, so this is where we got to with the Reckful stuff.
I'll just let it play through. No. He was this old streamer on
uh Twitch. One of the biggest You know so you know TTS, text
to speech?
So So Reckful was the guy who made that. He's the guy who He's
the guy who popularized and made that publicly accessible for
all streamers.
That can't be true that Reckful is the person who made TTS. That
That feels like that can't possibly be true, can Maybe he popularized
it. Maybe he's the first big streamer to jump on it.
I just feel like that has to be like the natural progression
of donations, no? Because Reckful was known for being one of
the most parasocial streamers of all time not only from his chat
to him but him to his chat and he wanted a way to connect better.
So he made TTS and he blew up dramatically cuz he was one of
the few shows ever have that. Um so anyways, Mizkif was one of
his old was one of his old best friends.
Mizkif farmed his audience after he committed because Mizkif
went to his house to figure out how he that way he could farm
him for views afterwards. So I would just completely disregard
everything he says. He's a massive manipulative piece of [__]
And uh yeah,
He's better off just being ignored, to be honest. Yeah. I feel
like Myron is going to get the sense very quickly that Teccy
also can't be trusted in any way. You know what I'm saying?
Teccy also comes off as kind of deranged doing this.
Like this is like an You know how you get that information tsunami
from somebody who's like kind of manic?
He's like totally manic as he's explaining this. You can tell.
I feel like Myron's got to be able to tell, right? No, no. I
mean, like I said, I I I hate it when whenever like guys get
falsely accused of Of course. So obviously that was I mean, you
saw what happened to Saikuno.
Yeah. Yeah, that's actually kind of crazy. I watched the girls
like super ass thing. It's like, dude, you went to his thing,
he did you, and you're like mad that you didn't get a relationship
out of it. >> Bro, these women are out of control. Dude,
these women are out of control. We need to put them back in the
kitchen. Honestly, I think we need to take their rights away.
Women need to go back to being second class citizens. It has
gotten so bad, dude, that cuz here's a here's a problem that
people need And this is like the uncomfortable talk no one wants
to have. The problem is this, women have all the same equal rights,
privileges, and accesses men as men.
PVD, you just accused Myron Gaines of lying about something.
There's a couple things I want you to be thinking about. Number
one, you are
Thank you, PVD. Thank you. I just wanted that clip, god. They
reserve the right to infantilize themselves at any point to escape
accountability, and it's ridiculous. Yeah. Like they'll sit there
and be
I don't think I really truly don't think that was about trying
to cancel Saikuno. I didn't get that impression. I think people
wanted drama farm it. They did successfully. I called out exactly
what was going on there. I think the DM Tectone revealed showed
that I revealed exactly or I called exactly what was going on
there. She was not trying to accuse him of assault. She was saying,
"This felt weird. Here's my story. This felt weird. I've been
feeling weird about it. Now seeing everybody else's story makes
me feel even more weird about it. Here it is." >> Go to
the club, get smashed, come back two or three years later and
say, "Oh, I regret that, so I'm going to say that it's like you."
Like she had the nerve to call herself a victim and Pokimane
as well, another dumb one. Like, dude, there's nothing worse
than giving women power. They're idiots. They're idiots. >> It
It is very scary where we live in a world where if you regret
a Dude, Tates Tone Tates Tone's in a room right now with somebody
How do I put this? It's like Tates Tone faked being a boxer and
he did it like somewhat convincingly and now he's like stepping
into the ring to spar with somebody who's actually a real boxer
who's got like an undefeated record. Like, this is a real misogynist
who really hates women. All right? You kind of like performed
this cuz what accused you of and you really didn't like that,
but it's not inherent. It's not like something you It's not something
you believe before and now Myron Gaines is stepping in here and
he's like throwing a couple jabs and Tates Tone's getting totally
filtered. Like Tates Tone can't compete. He can't actually compete.
At best he could copy. encounter a year and a half, two years,
three laters, three years later, you can ruin a man's life forever.
We're seeing this more and more often and and that's why, you
know, I mean, you know, it's like Kuno, he's obviously a piece
of [__] for cheating, obviously. I'm I'm not going
to condone
But also like, dude, him doing that probably saved a lot of people's
lives down the line. Now that we saw What was that? I think I
believe it's 17 women who have falsely accused him of being a
right now, so you know, I mean, it's
17 women have accused him of being a
Considering I went through the one that Tates Tone said that
did that, but they didn't at all, I somehow doubt >> Is
that Wait, he had a girlfriend at the time he was cheating? Yeah,
he had a girlfriend, yeah, five years, yeah. Oh, really? Let's
go, W. Okay.
let's go, W. He was over here slinging that Asian Let's go, man.
>> Okay, so not only did he have a girlfriend after all
of that, after he was exposed for 13 to like 18 other women,
the girl said,
"Stay away from സൈ Kuno. I'm staying with you. She didn't even
break up with him after. I don't know what type of hog Saikou
has. He's Asian you know I so I can't imagine much but like he
got to be pretty good at it. I I love that the one I watched
the one accusation with the Iceland accusation that Tectone read.
We watched it and Tectone accused her of calling Saikou up
when in the document itself it literally says she never met him
in real life.
It's totally crazy.
this is obviously not the correct story. The hog story that's
not what's happening here at all. >> the red pill is Every
time one of these women Saikou and doesn't get anything else
out of it they don't lose their mind because they don't have
a relationship. They they just don't want to be around him anymore.
>> He's Asian you know I so I can't imagine much but like
he got to be pretty good at it. The the red the red pill is simply
that if you're high status enough women will share you and they'll
accept the cheating dude. That's why like I'm up front with girls.
I tell them like look my thing is this I think guys should be
in a position where they could dictate the terms. Look I'm going
to be open you're going to be closed and that's just how it's
going to go because let's be honest most guys are going to cheat
if given the opportunity. So you might as well just be honest
and say look I want to have other women but you're going to be
closed on your end and be up front about it. Now I don't agree
with
Tectone go tell your girlfriend that. Tectone Tectone go tell
your girlfriend that right now. Go let her know go talk to he's
going to talk to Myron Gaines. He's going to go go let Sophia
know immediately. Actually I get to [__] other women's
mouths now.
That's the way it is Sophia and then because she benches significantly
more than him she's going to put him in an armbar or something
he's going to cry. >> cheating and like lying to your chick
I don't agree with that because that's kind of [__]
up. You got in under false pretenses and then you know she's
expecting something and you're not being honest about it but
I'm totally for guys
Oh so Myron understands. Myron Myron totally understands the
point of view. You see the little caveat he just did that basically
makes Saikou complete piece of [__] to him.
He just did that little caveat right there. Oh and also you should
just be honest about it. Lying's really bad, but you should be
honest about it. Just be honest and tell them you're going to
>> multiple women and then making their girls stay close
on their own. It It definitely works. If you If you have this
your [__] together, you can pull it off. That's why
his girl didn't leave him. What's she going to do? Go to another
guy that's going to cheat on her, too? That's like, you >> I
I just I just don't know why a guy would want to have a multiple
wife. Like, having one's, you know, it's a lot of work, you know?
Having two, that's It is a lot [snorts] of work, but I'll tell
you why it's good. Because um for women, right? Like
Okay, what I'm going to say right now doesn't represent anyone's
views
So confused. Are we pretending to be a trad groper or a leftist?
Are you asking about Tat Tone or Myron or me? except for mine.
Okay, so I'm going to say some some maybe some [__]
here that's very Cuz I don't even have to say any beliefs on
my end to point out hypocrisy from
Women are And what I mean by them being is they need
When have I ever pretended to be a trad groper? What?
They need to validate their man through the le-
I just think lying is bad. Uh You have no belief system. You're
You're like a total You're like a total
Okay, I fantastic self. Very high IQ
very high IQ moment. Amazing. Amazing stuff. lens of other people.
Let me explain what I mean by this. A girl will have a guy, right?
And be like, "Okay, this guy's attractive. I like him, right?"
But they're not going to know that they're making the right decision
until they go outside with that guy and other women look at him
and other men respect him, right? And the reason why I'm making
sure that I make this distinction that they need validation through
the lens of other people is because men are not like that. Like,
if me and you are at a club, right? And you see an attractive
girl and you're like, "Yo, I'm going to go talk to her. She's
attractive." And I tell you, "Oh, she's ugly." You'll be like,
"Fuck off, dude. I'm going to go talk to her." You don't need
my approval to go talk to her. You're just going to do what you're
going to do because you're a man, right? Women don't operate
that way. Women go off of um what other people think and then
if it's socially acceptable and then on top of that, they want
to ensure and know that they got the best man of all times. And
the only way for them to honestly assess that is they need um
validation from other women and then other men. In other words,
they want a guy that other women want to be with and other men
want to be. And since women need this validation from the external,
this is why they're
And since they need this external validation, there's no better
demonstration of higher value than having other women that want
you. Now, look, if you want to be monogamous, my opinion is if
you want to be monogamous, cool. No problem. Have one girlfriend.
I have no issue with that as long as your it's your choice. But,
you stay you need to stay attractive so your girl knows that
she could be replaced at any time because women are horrible
people when they have leverage.
Damn, [laughter] bro.
Dude, Tyto got no words in, man.
>> Yeah, I know. It sounds crazy, but it's the truth, man,
when it comes to women.
It's the truth.
>> I will say Myron does have like uh he's got like the
divine prophecy vibe when he is talking about women, okay? His
hatred for women is like universally understandable and perceptible.
Like when he starts ranting about how much he hates women, like
it actually it actually does
hit. It's like, dude,
you ever see a scene in like any animated show ever? Like anything
where like somebody taps into some divine energy and like the
beams of light shoot out of their eyes and their mouth and then
they start like talking in like this double or triple harmonized
voice, like the voice of God is speaking through them. I feel
like when Myron is asked about like what he thinks about women,
that's how he sounds. Like the the word of God is like running
through K. The the revelation of God is being
put out to the masses. That's how it feels when he's ranting
about women. That's how much he hates women. It's just like you
can feel there's like a misogynistic god that is using him as
a puppet and putting its its message out into the world.
Every time. >> if if guys understood this, right? About
like keeping their market value high and having other women that
want them, their girl would respect them way more and think twice
before doing some It's the only way to keep women in line, bro.
It's and it's a really ugly part about female nature, but it's
the truth about them. You know, as a guy where I've I've been
what? Maybe seven relationships in my lifetime. I'm I'm a, you
know, I like to be pretty realistic with myself. I'm not really
the greatest looking guy to be completely honest. I've been homes
before. I've had no money.
I've, you know, now I'm a
I've been 340 lbs. I've been a loser. I've, you know, been very
successful.
To me, I think the thing that keeps women's attention more than
anything cuz, you know, a lot of my viewers, you know, they don't
have never had a girlfriend. Maybe they haven't even had sex.
Dude.
You can't have sex.
>> growing
problem to some of these men. I don't really think you need looks
or money or any of that. I just think you just need to be the
most I I Dude, I There's something crazy about him like sort
of
telling on his audience like that to me.
Dude, those are the most cursed people on Earth that you haven't
had sex. You're like looking for somebody to inspire you to help
you to be better and you end up finding Tectone as a content
creator. Like you're actually it's over. Like
some divine force has filtered you that you would have that horrible
life that you would never be able to meet women or talk to women
and then you look up and the person like holding their hand out
to you to pick you up off the ground is
Like, listen. Listen, buddy. I know you've never had sex with
a woman, but what if I told you
you don't need their consent. And then the guy they clasp hands
and he pulls the guy up and then you hit the '80s music and they
run down the beach together. They just start running down the
beach together. Okay, amazing. most interesting person that they
can talk
Uh that's been my example. Like I I I just when a when a woman
talks to me, um I make sure that everybody else they ever talked
to is infinitely more boring. And I just really deep dive and
get to know who they are, what they like, what makes them interesting.
>> Dude, Myron about to blow this guy up. How how is Myron
going to act? >> I really do Cuz like you know, he's >> What
are your thoughts on this? I know I'm also furious that he's
ODing on stream cuz what the [__] is he doing? And
I wish he would, you know, have somebody like check him a little
bit cuz I don't want to see that guy dying. That would That would
break my heart. He's like 21. But he's kind of talking about
how you need to be So you need to be successful. For me, I just
think you just need to be And just make your life story to them
and make them think that you're like truly the most like the
the Seki's commercial. Make them think that you're the most interesting
man in the world and I think a lot of things that for me, the
way that I talk
I will say there's something to this that people basically don't
have a good idea of seeing like they people can't see what the
truth is in any situation.
And so if you're willing to just lie or if you're willing to
play a character and have a story, that's enough to basically
get most of what you want in the world. It's like
unfortunate. It doesn't last usually.
talk to women or have talked to women. Obviously, I'm engaged
now is just uh make sure that uh everybody else People don't
know how to talk to girls, in my opinion. I don't think they
need to I don't think they know how to talk to them at all. And
I think if you can make a woman actually feel heard, that's kind
of the way that you can kind of keep them by your side forever.
And and they will actually give a [__] about
For me, um you know, look, I I I would
>> Myron is like so Myron is like seething internally right
now. That's crazy. Look, man, he's going to be soft on Toe cuz
Myron Myron is good at, you know, engaging with people. You got
to understand Myron couldn't just be like, you can't go from
zero to NHH
in zero in 5 seconds, okay? You can't do that. You got to be
able to work people up to where you're at and Myron can bring
his energy down a little bit and talk to people, especially when
they're bigger people, like bigger creators or whatever. So,
he is going to Myron is going to pull it back a little bit. He's
going to say he's wrong. He disagrees. But, I do think he'll
like actually lay it out a little bit. And then they will actually
give a [__] about you. Look, I I I wish it were that
way, man. That like just be having >> I wish I wish it
was like just be a good guy and and that'll and that'll go. But,
like the thing is this like and I'm glad that you brought up
Clavicular because Clavicular has kind of brought to light what
I've been talking about forever and it's like
what he's basically demonstrating is that he's demonstrating
hypergamy at like a super high level with women, right? Which
is like he's going to the clubs, he's making out these girls,
he's a good looking guy, he's got cameras following him, he has
money, etc. So, he has like the trifecta, right? And what he's
showing on stream is how women actually behave from a carnal
perspective if they're faced with a more attractive guy. Girls
that are in committed relationships, girls that are married,
women that have a guy that they're talking to or that they're
with and he's like pulling them from them. Like he's red pilling
people real time.
Does any pay some of those girls? I'm guessing anytime they've
had like a story where it's like a girl with a boyfriend who's
come to talk that's all just scripted. And Myron buys it because
Myron believed that to begin with, but it's obviously scripted.
>> any high value women. He's talking like attractive women,
but all these women are just useless. They're going to [__]
them once and they're going to hop on the next train. Like >> That's
what That's the majority That's the majority of females, though.
I think that's I think that's the majority of people, to be honest.
Cuz I mean what What's the average cheating rate? 70% of non-married
couples? Yeah, but men aren't It's only women are Men are know
[__] makers.
You think so? I know a lot of horny men. Yeah, well, here's the
thing, right? I'll explain what I mean by this. For a man, right?
For you to be a promiscuous as a man, you have to bring value
to the table. To be a promiscuous as a woman, you don't have
to bring any value to the >> That that I can It is a lot
easier to get than it is to get because any woman will slap a
paper bag on you and run you over. They don't give a [__]
about who you are all that. No, sure. Yeah, it is a lot easier
to be a hoe. So, that's why I don't >> Yeah, it's a lot
more rewarding as well cuz like any woman can have the backup
plan of just booting up an OnlyFans account there for for $5.
Absolutely
Yeah, and and this is why like when when I see guys that like
smash a lot of girls, I know What a high-level conversation.
Let's
>> But if I see a girl that smashed a lot of guys, she's
definitely doing something wrong. So, that's why like cuz women
will try to sit there and be like, "Oh, well, you're a hoe, too."
and they'll use it in a pejorative sense. And it's like, uh no,
[__] You're the hoe. We're the Like women don't have
like there's no skill for a woman to smash, but there's plenty
of skill for a guy to smash. So, like whenever like it when whenever
I see a guy that's like getting women, I know he's doing something
right. And again, I'm not telling guys to run around and smash
every girl that they can. I'm just saying that guys need to be
aware of this very, you know, [clears throat] polarizing dynamic
between the two genders and that like women and men are not the
same. And like I know you said before like, "Hey, just have a
good personality, whatever." I do think it's important It's not
so much good personality. Just have good communication skills
to where you can entertain like entertain their brain rather
than just like I don't know. You got to understand. I'm a guy.
I'm 32 years old. I've never really given a [__]
about sex at all. I don't care if
It helps when you are terrified of
Come on, man.
Does it not? >> For me, sex is something that you do with
one person that like you love because you want to have like a
sacred bond. I'm not about beating guts. I've had opportunities,
you know, to do that type of [__] I'm just not interested.
I don't care. I'd rather play a [__] video game.
I'm I'm going to be completely [__] honest. Uh This
guy is a deal. >> and that's fine. Um, look, I'm not Everybody's
different. Some guys are horn dogs, some guys aren't. It's fine.
Like some guys want to be monogamous and if they want to do that,
um, that's completely cool. But what I will say is that I think
with women, um, you know, being interesting is like that's cool.
Obviously being inter-
The entire red pill movement is basically the game Neil Strauss
repackaged for his sales. Yeah, obviously. Wait, did you not
understand that this came from the pickup
The red pill is just pickup. It's just pickup artists. It's not
even repackaged. It's literally the same thing. I Yeah.
Yeah, I don't Yeah, obviously.
>> Yeah, that's that's like intentional and they know that
and they're aware of
Like I think it's basically it's the exact same Yeah. >> You
have to be like but you have to meet like the requirements first
where she even gives a [__] about your personality,
right? So like you got to be you have you have to because most
women like look at most men as like invisible. Like most guys
don't even >> Absolutely, 100%. They don't exist. Yes.
The growing Yeah, the growing amount of men that I know that
have never had sex before is and who who wants but have never
gotten is absurd. I don't think I know a single female virgin.
Yeah, no, they're not, dude. And if you take like an average
21-year-old female and an average 21-year-old guy, these women
are running laps. And like I get what you're saying, being charismatic
and having a personality is important, but you need to have all
the other things in place where she'll even give you a chance.
Cuz like there's plenty of guys that are funny as hell. You definitely
don't. I Like you definitely don't. And Tectone should be able
to push back against that. But I do think that
I think the weird thing is some of the guys who want to push
back against that have a lot of money and have a lot of other
things going on. And Myron will like kind of insidiously trick
them.
So Tectone thinks it's all his personality, but he wasn't picking
up hot women when he was just some random ago, right? He doesn't
have this world-beating personality that he thinks he does. And
I I think Byron can tap into that and turn him to the dark side.
Byron, turn him to the dark side right >> super charming,
super charismatic, but they're not tall enough, or they don't
make enough money, or they're not good-looking enough, so the
girls don't even give a [__] about their personality.
Cuz like look at like let's we use clavicular. He goes up to
the girls like, "Hey, are we are we going to you know, are you
going to get cracked tonight?" No, I'm like, "Okay, cool. I'm
going to go talk to another girl." She's like, "Okay, I'll
Like this is this is the this is like the this is like the real
like reality when it comes to women, bro. Like this is what it
is. And and the thing is is like I know a lot of people say,
"Oh, not all women are like that." A lot of them are, bro. Most
women are So, I'm just going to be honest. And and I'll tell
you why. Because feminism, the reason why most women are is because
society tells them that they can play the field, have the
have fun, go to college, be degenerate, experiment, and then
when you're 29, 30, and you have your career, you can go ahead
and find a family at the end of it. Like this is what we advertise
to women now. It No, it's a shame. I I had a talk about this.
I think the generation of women is probably the most debaucherous,
to keep you know, to keep it light. And it's a shame because
you know, obviously I'm a guy where I want a family. I want to
have a daughter. I want to have a kid. And to raise them in this
generation where you know, we're currently encouraging little
children to chop their off because they watch a Netflix show
and a cow told them that they actually identify more as a woman
than a man. I think it's horrible the brainwash that we're putting
into people. I think it's ridiculous that we're actually getting
to a point where I get constantly for ho shaming and Well, you
should be. You absolutely should be. We should not be promoting
these promiscuous lifestyles by any stretch of the imagination
because it's going to lead to the death of our society. Nobody
trusts each other. Everybody knows they're just I mean to find
a good woman is nearly impossible these days. And the [clears throat]
other thing is the value
And I want to talk I can only talk about my life. And
when you're a content creator in in my
they can ruin your life forever
if they just say, "By the way, [clears throat] all that consensual
sex we had, well, actually no, it wasn't because I changed my
mind because I had a conversation with a friend 2 years later."
And I think that's in
This totally
How long can this guy ever go without thinking about Pink and
bringing her up in conversations? It's like zero It's It's like
30 minutes tops. He's talking to another human, he's going to
start talking about Pink almost immediately. >> incredibly
horrifying. And a minute That That's being publicized right now.
And that's happening to the normal average day, you know, average
Joe, where that has happened to their father, that's happened
to their brother, that's currently happening to them, where people
don't see it
to be worth to be in a relationship because that is kind of how
it's becoming the status quo. Now, once
I don't want to lie to you, man. I don't think all women are
I think there are There's a higher percentage, absolutely. The
average is >> like 85. I think [laughter] like 85% is I'm
not even trying This is what I told you guys, okay? Yeah, it's
like a black belt misogynist against like somebody who
took like who took like 2 days of karate lessons once.
That's what That's the difference we're dealing with here, okay?
>> I literally think like 85% of them are morons. Cuz I
go to these college campuses, dude. These are supposed to be
the cream of the crop women, and they're
Like it's nuts, dude. So, okay, the cream of the crop women,
I'm going to tell you where they're at, okay? Okay, where? They're
at Barnes & Noble.
>> If you're >> Yeah, they're reading fiction novels
like they're reading Most women read fiction, by the way, cuz
Dude, okay. One,
I'm pretty sure you've already identified that being chased is
something you wanted of women, and let me tell you,
the the lib talk
literature crowd, that is not those people, okay?
Those are not the like good girls who are going to I'm just telling
you that's that's facts.
I'm That was the dumbest thing I've ever heard in my life.
The the all the cream of the crop of the good girls are The good
girls are at Barnes No, they're not. Cuz they're >> not.
They don't read non-fiction. They read romance novels. That's
their Well, the romance is how I got bit by a werewolf and then
fell in love with
>> It's it's bad. Yeah, but yeah, you got to find a good
chick by you know, meeting them This is so bad.
I think gym rats are honestly pretty good people, too. I don't
I don't think anybody going to the club is going to be worth
a damn. I think meeting somebody at the club, you're [__]
Maybe meet a girl playing League of Legends. Go bot lane, play
AD carry. Meet them there. Have them play support and then you
know, bond over 6 months as you grind them out of bronze into
silver tier. But it's funny because I was talking about this
the other day on stream. Finding a good woman for your for yourself
is pretty much near impossible in your local area. I'm noticing
the amount of importing
that people are having to do of women from other countries or
from you know, five states up. They got to fly them out to stay
with you because it it is incredibly hard to find a good woman
these days. Yeah, the passport bro thing like because here's
the thing like all of these different you know, Dude, what?
There's so many dumb things being said at the same time. Like
strategies have developed because okay, so basically this what's
going on.
Women are have become insufferable and quite frankly are not
worth the headache a lot of the times, right? So men have kind
of dealt with it in multiple ways. Some guys have said, you know
what? I'm just going to go monk mode. Other guys have said, I'm
going to go my own way. Other guys said, I'm going to just learn
game and smash as many of them as I can. Other guys are like,
I'm going to go leave the country and get my passport. Other
guys, I'm going to import a girl in. But I would argue that all
of us have pretty much identified the same problem in the West
or countries where feminism is prominent where women are insufferable
and quite frankly most of the time don't make for good girlfriends
and even worse wives. Women want to get married but they don't
want to necessarily be wives. So guys are dealing with it in
different ways. >> Because they're rewarded for that
Of course. That is that is how the world it's put women on a
pedestal and men really just have to bust their ass, you know,
like a seven out of 10 guy with like six figures who's six foot
is going to settle for like a three out of 10 woman because you
know, at least
Where is that Where is that even
What do we By the way, the other thing I'll say about this is
all the people I know who are truly like happy in life I know
like maybe five people who are like some level of happy that
I could aspire to.
>> Every single one of them
is in a relationship that started around or before they turned
25.
And that went long-term they had kids.
That's like all of the happiest people I
Like honestly to some extent I'm not even like I don't have kids
obviously so I it's not impossible but I'm just saying that that's
like all of the happy. Those are the people who are like on a
good track. You should be trying to get onto that track, okay?
As best you can you should be trying to get onto that track.
Build something long-term.
when you have kids and you get a house together or some that
like ties you together so you actually have to work on your problems.
You just try being in a relationship only for like two years
and you never ever do anything else. You just like sometimes
talk sometimes but never have any joining of your lives. Yeah,
it doesn't work out. Yeah, obviously things are going to get
[__] up cuz when things actually get bad you've nothing
that tethers you to the relationship,
Sometimes you just need something that ties you guys together.
Cuz otherwise yeah, there's just I feel like that's the biggest
problem with like modern dating right now.
People don't have any reason to suffer through any like
points. They think that person might not [__] another
man. That the odds are lower. Uh but the it is
all of the good women I'm sorry, all of the hot women have only
fans. And you don't want to date a prostitute.
Uh and then
all the other ones are impossible to find. They're most likely
already married or already in a relationship.
Uh so there's not really any way to find any good ones.
Yeah, it's very hard. You got to you know, I tell this is why
I tell guys you got to date a girl for like 6 months to 1 year
before you even give her a serious relationship or like start
like taking her seriously because um you know, a lot of girls
are very good at at um feigning um good girlness. Like, "Oh yeah,
I'm pure." Cuz like, you know, up front she's going to pretend
to be a good girl and I'm pure X XYZ. And like over like 6 months
to 1 year you'll be able to pick up on like bad habits and like
be able to like, you know, kind of keep it in the back of your
mind. Um because there's a lot of red flags that you can look
for in girls that you'll be like, "Uh yeah, I don't know if I
want to take this girl." Man, I got this feeling yesterday when
I was talking to or when I was watching the ContraPoints thing.
It's so weird to me when people have the exact same thoughts
on everything that they did a year ago. A year ago is like maybe
acceptable. But if you don't have like some updated thoughts,
if you don't if you're not evolving, if you're not watching things
and seeing your like thoughts on things evolve a little bit,
I felt this way with ContraPoints where I'm like, "Dude, I
you got your opinions from like 6 years ago. That seems really
bad. Like you haven't grown in 6 years. You don't see where you
were wrong. I feel like people who can't see where they were
wrong and be honest about it. Uh those people scare me, man.
And Myron Myron seems that way. Not that he thinks he's wrong.
But it's just like the exact same spiel I had to suffer through
on like a Destiny stream like eight different
And I'm just not really here for it anymore. I mean, I'm listening
to it. I'm it's not that bad. I it's more Bro, you really got
the same spiel still?
Really? Well, seriously, that might take time to develop for
you to find out. What what are you Be fair, Contra was in a drug
case for most of that time, no? I've no idea. >> red flags
you think? Okay, sure. Um Does she obey? Does she like listen
to to what you say, right? Um like without giving you, you know,
pushback or Does she have guy friends? Um is she on you know,
on social media all the time and have a Wait, Sophia Sophia's
on social media all the time. And she's at the gym cuz she's
a fit influence fitness influencer.
So she does have guy friends and
Wait. Off. Off. photos of herself. Um does she like going to
the club or going like drinking a lot or doing drugs or that
stuff? >> Club is a red flag. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. So
like these are all things to like look for. Does she travel a
lot? What's her relationship with her father like, right? Um
you know, does she have strong men in her life? And what I've
noticed is like girls that don't have a strong father, brother,
or uncle in their life, some some type of male [clears throat]
some male character that's a leadership male leadership in her
life, they tend to be all kinds of [__] up. So like
there's a whole bunch of different things that I go Hm. I just
want to see, just for the sake of it, scantily clad photos. What
are we counting as a scantily clad
Are these Would this count as a scantily clad photo?
Got a lot of thigh there, sweetheart.
I don't know. I don't know, man. I don't know, Takedown. It seems
like we're seeing a lot of the red flags here,
I'm seeing a lot of those red flags right now. Are you sure this
is the Are you sure By the way, I don't have any problem with
this. It's
It's not my problem. It's Takedown's problem. And that's why
he's sitting here like, "Hm. Wow, all of those red flags apply
to my girlfriend."
go for. But like yeah, like some big red flags is like her Instagram
profile, how she dresses, does she submit, does she behave, does
she understand male and female dynamics,
does she respect you, etc. All these different things. >> So
I think that's another one that you just brought. The first one
you brought does obey, does she comply, does she like uh I can't
remember the I can't remember the exact word you used. Um but
that's one of the biggest issues. >> obey Yeah, obey. >> Listen
to you. Does she obey? That's That's what people have a really
big issue with is the terminology of which that is used because
>> People People don't like when you say that, you know?
Yeah, they get mad at that. They do. Um and it's very hard >> thing,
that's a good way to vet with Oh man, Taqtone is Taqtone should
not have had this conversation cuz I guarantee you
Sophia's got to be like a relatively modern woman, right?
You know what I'm saying? And I feel like she's going to know
who Myron Gaines is cuz all women know who Myron Gaines is, basically.
Like they got the word out kind of like the Andrew Tate
She's going to know about this conversation. This is going to
cause so many problems for him cuz he has such a fragile ego
that I know Myron's going to hit him in a few ways that he's
going to make it an issue. I feel like Myron I'm watching Myron
like slowly do surgery in this guy's brain in a way that his
relationship is blowing up in 3 to 6
If he has 80 IQ, bro, I don't know what she is.
I I don't know. I Like you can say that, but who knows like what's
been going on there, really?
I just feel like Myron's going to [__] this up for
him. I feel like Myron's definitely [__] this up
right now. Women, like use the word obey and see how she responds.
If she gets mad at you using the word obey, she's and you probably
don't want to take her seriously because like that's a fantastic
word to like filter out girls because it's in the Bible, bro.
Like if a girl says, "I'm a god-fearing woman." You say, "Okay,
you need to obey your husband." "What do you mean?" Okay, get
the [__] out of here. Like instant identify. Like
get this girl out of here. But sorry, go ahead. You were
Maybe this might be way too much. This is probably way too much
for me to really put into like this is a mind read on a on a
level I that's irresponsible,
I feel like when he was like, "That word obey, I feel like he
talked to Sophia about about interviewing Myron and this would
have been something they talked about. He says you have to obey.
He says women have to obey. He doesn't think women have agency
or something like this. I or he's had that conversation with
a different woman somewhere along the way. Maybe not the current
girlfriend, but some girlfriend. Okay? And I think he's like
thinking through that conversation. That's why he's talking back
right now. The internet once again has brainwashed a lot of women
to think that if your husband tells you to do something and you
do it, he's manipulating you. They use words like manipulate
you, that they're oppressing you, that they're abusing you, that
they're they're gaslighting you and it's become so hard to even
communicate with the opposite especially in a relationship sense
because it's kind of like a no matter what the man does, he's
wrong.
Bro, a guy like saying obey and a guy who knows what he's doing
saying obey are two different things. Obey means when I say don't
cheat on me, they obey. It does not mean a slave as you are all
No, obey doesn't Obey means obey. Obey means you literally give
up your agency and trust the other person that when they tell
you to do something, you do it. That's what Myron means by obey.
He means obey.
He means like a slave. It's just with the understanding that
he won't use it like you're a slave.
But he means the same way. He means like when I say something,
you're not asking me That's how they define it in the red pill,
right? When I tell you you have to do something, you need to
do it without giving me like pushback. You just need to do it
because I'm I'm doing what's best for us and you trust me. That's
how they define it. And this isn't for all women. Um but for
a lot of women, they will think that if they do what they're
Just to be clear, just as one final reinforcement, that's why
Andrew Tate says, when I say obey, I mean obey because if we're
in a life or death situation and I tell you to go this way and
you don't listen to me, you start like beep beep beep beep beep
beep beep and then we both get shot, I'm going to be angry.
Right? He told that he's had this stupid story, this like little
parable he tells about this. It's like, "Dude, what if we're
in a What if there's assassins coming for us and I need you to
zig and you zag?
Well, it's over for us." It's like, "Okay, that's stupid." >> is
telling them to do
that they're being abused or they're being, you know, in an abusive
relationship and it's awful because then what will happen is
there'll be two people in a perfectly normal healthy relationship
and everything will be going fine and then they will tell their
friends what they did or they'll tell their guy friends, you
know, the guys who are waiting in line waiting for them to have
an issue that way they can say, "Oh my god, he did what? I would
I can't believe he did that to you. That's awful. Come over.
Tell me about what's going on in your relationship." Those [__]
fact are the pre-orders, the beta testers. It's awful because
anything can be made to sound terrible. Like, "Oh yeah, you know,
I got my girl to make me some food." "Oh my god, so he he told
you to make him a sandwich? Oh my god, that's terrible." Everybody's
trying to spin everything into the very forward and we we haven't
got We haven't really got this part of the internet yet because
everybody talks about the misogyny that happens in the world
but the misandry is even worse and if you call out you're called
an incel. Uh but man hate is at an all time high. And so I I
understand and maybe I'm wrong, Myron. Maybe I'm wrong. I understand
a lot of things that you say.
I mean, misandry probably is at an all time high. Just general
like discord between this is at an all time high. Yeah, for sure.
>> I think and maybe you do believe everything to the exact
degree that you say. I think you're limit testing, personally.
I think you're saying this thing that I say that I totally believe,
I'm going to turn it up just to piss some people off because
you kind of have to. You We're having to We can't play the game
the way that they've been playing the game for two decades now.
We have to go above and beyond to level the playing field because
the outward misogyny and the outward misandry, we have to be
so misogynistic to catch up to how much misandry's been in the
shadows in order to get on an equal playing field. A lot of this
and you know, I'm not sure if you saw this with the um the the
whole Sakuna drama. There's this VTuber who kind of blew up by
being a massive misandrist, which is her name's Bao. Which is
a shame because I mean I met her like 5 years ago. She was honestly
decent. And then she found out
It's so funny seeing this guy, man.
This guy's crazy.
Going to start talking about Bao now. By the way, Bao went live
totally proved that she had nothing to do with this. Totally
proved that she was like doing just totally a normal thing. And
then she off >> popular you can get by just [__]
on men non-stop even though you cater to men and 90% of your
audience is men. You got to make Also, Bao is like an only fans
VTuber or something.
I don't even know. How could she possibly be that misandrist?
>> that you say that all men are >> Is she really?
But uh
>> Yeah, um it's not I think everything and this is why
I say being important communication, being charismatic is very
important communication skills are at an all-time And if you
can't properly undo the brainwash and the propaganda that women
have been fed and I agree a lot of women are [__]
stupid. Um if you can't undo that, you're never going to find
the hope to actually finding someone who is going to love you
for the rest of your life and not [__] [__]
another dude the moment they get an opportunity to do
um you brought up some really good points there. Like for example,
misandry. Most people don't even know what that word is, right?
Like everyone knows I know. It's so bad. And most people know
about misogyny and half these women don't even know the proper
definition, but they don't even know what misandry is. And and
there's a reason why no one knows what misandry is. It's because
disrespecting men, treating men like [__] is completely
socially acceptable. Now, going back to the whole obey thing,
right? Because I I I I thought it was interesting that you had
mentioned that. Sure. The reason why the word obey is a problem,
right? And uh women doing what they're supposed to do or standing
or you know, filling in their roles. The The why is because what
feminism has done since the 1960s is is blurred gender roles
and it's made female roles nebulous. It used to be she's the
mother, she's the homemaker, she takes care of the children,
etc. Right? She's the nurturer. But thanks to feminism, we've
made it where women can do both. They can go ahead and chase
a career, but they can also go ahead and be a wife or be a mom
or whatever. And what this has basically done is it's kept the
male role static while female roles are negotiable and while
females Hey, hold on. I need to check this really quickly, okay?
I need to see do we get back on to Israel at some point?
Cuz that's honestly what I'm sitting here like hoping for is
we get back on to Let me search it in the transcript.
Dude, there's at least one time where they talk about people
and not in the context of Israel at all. Cuz I was thinking that
how how do you think these
narratives became spread so mainstream? Do you think it's within
each other where it just happened organically or do you think
it's other countries trying to implement the idea of just uh
never have kids, never have families? Cuz I was thinking that
There was the There was something that happened a long time ago
where a lot of people were AstroTurfing Asmongold and I always
thought it was just, you know, the Americans saying Asmongold.
Then I realized it was China who was AstroTurfing It was all
Chinese websites, which makes no sense, where they were AstroTurfing
against Asmongold to seem more hated and more controversial than
he actually is just because he's saying things that would actually
I believe benefit the majority of men.
What? Americans max hearing. Do you think there's any chance
that China is implementing like anti-family propaganda in order
to have a way to reduce our population without being direct and
having global warfare? Or is that like insane tinfoil hat Alex
Jones What?
Hold on. Hold on. I got to was China who was AstroTurfing It
was all Chinese websites, which makes no sense, where they were
AstroTurfing against Asmongold it seems hated and more controversial
than he actually
Ascher trafficking hate against
>> just because he said things that would actually, I believe,
benefit the majority of Americans from actually hearing. Do you
think there's any chance that China is implementing like anti-family
propaganda in order to have a way to reduce our population without
being direct and having global warfare? Or is that like insane
tinfoil hat Alex
totally insane on the anti-family thing from China.
Dude, okay.
But also,
even if it wasn't, how in the Why would they waste their money
targeting all of the virgin, hopeless losers that watch Asmongold?
That is the worst investment of money. I'm going to stop the
American family from forming, and my goal is to basically make
Asmongold look bad. How
How? How What?
In what Wait, how How does Asmongold looking bad contribute
How does Asmongold looking bad contribute to more kids being
born?
Sorry, less fewer kids being born.
How does it contribute to kids being born in any way, positive
or negative,
No, no, I I China definitely has a vested interest in our failure
um to some degree. Um like they're they're they're they're playing
the slow game, right? Like um and this is why like So, one of
the things that I'm super critical of is wars in the Middle East
I like where your head's at with the conspiratorial thinking,
Tectone. I'm going to change the subject to something that is
not related at all cuz I don't want to tell you you're right.
So, I'm going to change the subject to some other conspiracy
that I can get you on board for. Let me tell you. Let me tell
you about wars in the Middle East.
I look at it like what the [__] are we doing, you
know, fighting wars in the Middle East when the real adversary
is China. Like we've been wasting money uh getting our soldiers
killed, fighting wars, pointless wars in the Middle East for
the benefit of Israel. Yeah. Um and that's been like keeping
us away from progressing and increase our ingenuity in building
up our economy to compete with China, who is rapidly growing,
right? Like rapidly going growing in many different ways. And
what they're doing is like they're taking over strategic markets,
right? That can really hurt us in the long run. So, um this is
um when I talk about like, you know, why I'm so opposed to Middle
Eastern foreign wars, it's because we're falling behind to China.
And we're so, you know, we're stuck in these the stupid ass sandbox
that literally has no real strategic benefit for us at all. Have
you ever been to Afghanistan?
No, I've never been, no. I I keep on being told that it's an
amazing place, but I can't I can't wrap my head around that because
What? Sorry, I walked away for a second.
How was his answer, "Have you ever been to Afghanistan?"
>> Did he "For the benefit of Israel." Listens, listens,
listens.
"Have you ever been to Afghanistan?"
>> He really doesn't want to talk about Israel, guys. 9/11.
I grew up in a military family during 9/11. And I can't imagine
being any Oh, no. Hey, Tectone, you want to you switched the
topic to 9/11, but guess who actually did 9/11?
Uh-oh.
About to get a new knowledge dump on this guy. You think you
can run away by changing the topic? Turns out Byron Gaines can
turn any topic into another topic, okay? Amazing. Amazing.
>> dark wizards bombing [__]
I just I can't imagine that. Yeah. You should talk to Arab. I
I've had him on my show. He's He's a Christian Lebanese guy,
nice guy, awesome guy. He went and he actually spent time with
the Taliban. He was there. Yeah, he did a whole He was hanging
out with them and recording a vlog and everything. And look,
at the end of the day, man, um you know, we had no business in
Afghanistan. I don't know why the hell we were there. Um What's
the wild man
Nah, nah, that was a lot.
Not so much, no. It's
I mean, I don't know if you want to get into the like basically
all the wars in the Middle East, bro, are fought for Israel's
benefit. Like Israel [laughter] wants to be a hegemon in the
Middle
We they have an enormous amount of lobbying power in the United
States and an enormous amount of representation at higher levels
and they lobby our politicians to fight wars in the Middle East
for the benefit of Israel um under the guise of national security.
>> that I need to look into because like from birth I have
been like if I'm on a plane and there's someone with a turban
on, I'm like, "Okay, so in case things go sideways, >> let
me get near the emergency exit." And there's nothing wrong with
that. We're look, there's nothing wrong with stereotyping people.
I do it, too. You know, if I see a a guy that's a fellow Arab,
I'm like, "Oh, shit." So, I get it. Um but uh you know, and and
and I totally understand that. But I do think that it's important
um and I wish more Americans like understood Middle Eastern foreign
policy and understood like what's really going on over there
in the Middle East and a lot of it, right, is like propaganda,
dude. Like um there's been like an insane push from the Zionist
lobby to push like anti-Muslim propaganda and be like, "Oh, yeah,
these guys are the enemies. They're trying to kill us, blah blah
blah." All this other [__] But like if we're going
to be very honest, bro, the real people that are like the radicals
are actually the Israeli Jews. Like a lot of people don't know
this. October 7th, one of the reasons October 7th happened was
because the Israelis are trying to destroy a mosque in Jerusalem
called the Al-Aqsa Mosque. This mosque is the third holiest site
in all of the Islamic faith. And what they're trying to do is
they're trying to rebuild the third temple and they imported
a bunch of red cows from Texas, your home state, to Israel that
they plan to slaughter. We're going to go [laughter] We went
from zero to red heifer in no time flat, guys. Holy [__]
Tek Tot is now hearing about the red heifer conspiracy, the red
heifer
ritual. Let's go. to bring back their to bring their Messiah,
right? And they'll sit there and they'll say, "Oh, yeah, these
guys over in Iran are crazy, radical clerics, blah blah blah."
Okay,
But, you guys literally are trying to destroy a mosque, start
a war in the Middle East, start all these problems. You guys
are passing legislation to hang Palestinians, right? Like, the
Israelis are actually the real radical religious crazy nut jobs.
It's just that no one ever talks about this cuz it gets you
look, we can you know, two things can be true at the same time.
You can go ahead and talk about the jihadis and the radical Muslims.
Taitaitaitai just hates it. All he knows is, "Don't talk about
the Jews, guys. We'll get banned." And he's just sitting here
like
"I don't Can you just not talk about Ah." He's like pretending
he's okay with it. He's not okay with it. He's not been okay
with it. He's tried to change the topic every single time it's
come back >> Fair, no problem. But, we have to be honest
and also say that there's a radical problem as well, and that's
what everyone is terrified to actually
So, I haven't really gotten into the
the Israel thing too much.
I have a buddy. Do you know who Nux Taku
No. Damn.
>> Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. I I don't
know if I can say I forgive Taitaitai. I will stop sharking Taitaitai
for a period of 1 month at minimum if Taitaitai sets up a Nux
Taku Myron Gaines conversation.
If that happens, I will stop sharking on Taitaitai for a month
at least.
I promise you I will swear off Taitaitai content for a month
if that conversation. If I get Nux Taku
Myron knowing who it is, and Myron goes to that Oh my god, yes.
One of the best out there. And so, I hear a lot of
One of the best out there.
the most But, you know, we work with what we can. >> I
still haven't I haven't really heard from someone who's well-researched
about why the Jews are the issue. So, if if were to explain to
me as a as a guy who would admit that they're quite ignorant
on that subject, what what would that be if you were to explain
why the Jews? [laughter] Oh my god. We're about to witness the
other topic where Myron Gaines has the voice of God running through
him, okay?
Now, if you had to say to somebody who didn't know what they
were talking somebody who didn't know much about the region if
you had to explain to them why people are bad, what would you
say and Myron Gaines
the light comes out of his eyes and his
He lights up. He rises several feet off the ground. Starts speaking
with his booming voice of command. It all started in Egypt, my
son. And we'll see where it
Well, I'll I'll angle it from the America First perspective.
And then if you want to go deeper into the lore, we can do that.
But I'll I'll simplify it this way. >> Oh, no.
I wanted the lore part. Dude, I swear I had no idea about like
anti-Semitism. I always talk about this until I watched some
stream with Zherka and Nick Fuentes and Myron Gaines and Sneako.
And Myron and Nick started talking about how people moved across
Europe with like banking and how it like was the rise and fall
of empires and they're trying to explain how every European empire
like over the entire like Dark Ages into the Renaissance and
forward rose and fell behind like banking basically. I'm like,
holy This is like the encyclopedia of anti-Semitism right now.
It was It was crazy to watch. So, I was I hope you're going to
get a replay of that. >> enormous amount of representation
and power in the United States that they utilize to the benefit
of a foreign nation that puts us in a precarious situation geopolitically.
That makes sense. If I was to put it nice and succinctly in one
sentence, that's that's basically the root of the problem. >> to
do that is so important.
>> Yeah. I'm glad you made that short. No, it's not. That's
actually worthless. You don't even know what he said. You just
think he's done talking. But, as the transcript clearly shows,
I have multiple instances of Israel being said over the next
like 30 seconds. So, whatever you thought you just did, Tact
Tone, it didn't work. Okay? And he's going to keep going. >> Don't sweat.
Okay. Yeah. Okay, I get you. Yeah. Cuz people a lot of people
like spurg out on it and like they'll just like go into random
rants. But like that's basically the problem. Like right now
this war with Iran, like we are fighting that for the Israelis.
And anyone that disagrees with me, go ahead and search Marco
Rubio,
uh you know preemptive attack, and you're going to see Marco
Rubio admits he probably shouldn't have admitted this, but the
Israelis were going to attack the Iranians no matter what. And
if the And the Iranians warned the United States and Iran uh
sorry, and Israel that if we attack if if either Israel or the
United States attacked Iran, they were going to retaliate against
both. So, when the Israelis said we're going to attack no matter
what, that dragged us into the war. That is why Trump had to
get involved and, you know, go ahead get involved in this war.
And now we're in a political quagmire, bro, cuz like I Look,
Fox News is going to tell you we're winning the war. We are losing
this war in every single way. Do not fall for the propaganda
from Fox News because it's to impose your political whim on another
group of people from a strategic pur- purpose.
This war, before the war, the Strait of Hormuz was open, all
the bases were fully functional in the Middle East. Yes, we destroyed
their navy and their air force, but that doesn't matter because
that was never the problem in the first place. Now they're rushing
towards a nuclear bomb. All of our allies in the Gulf are pissed
off at us. All of our military bases in the region are gone.
And quite frankly, now Iran has us by the balls cuz they're like,
"Look, we're not going to negotiate with you guys until you guys
lift the sanctions, get your bases the [__] up out
of here with so we lose our ability to be in the Middle East.
Uh you guys got to We're going to continue to have people go
through Strait of Hormuz and pay us. And if you don't, we're
just going to keep attacking your allies in the Gulf, make you
look weak." And what this war has basically done is it's created
an energy crisis. It's humiliated us geopolitically because we
can't even defend our allies that we claim to defend.
It's made us look like clowns, and then we're spending an enormous
amount of money to fight this war, like $2 billion a day. So,
strategically speaking, we are losing this war. Yes, we're blowing
up Iran. Yes, we're destroying their navy. Yes, we're destroying
their air force, but that doesn't matter cuz they're bliss-
Now, this is a dumbass take. Sorry. Well, yeah, these guys all
think Byron's a third worldist. >> program is the real
danger, and those There's hundreds of them underground that we
don't have the bunker busters to get into and destroy. And even
if we destroy one or two of them, it doesn't matter. There's
hundreds of them all over the country. Iran's a big country,
bro. It's like the size of Western Europe with 90 million people,
and they have an army that's a million people. And we're not
going to effectuate the regime that they want without boots on
the ground. So, it'd be an Iraq for like 10 Oh, right, with Iran.
Yeah, so Byron's not totally wrong here in that it doesn't matter
in terms of the energy crisis, but it does matter in terms of
like Iran's long-term prosperity. Iran is getting They are getting
crippled by all the bombing. Like, it is bad for their their
country, obviously,
but it's like it's not going to help the US. The US is like punching
themselves in the face repeatedly. Strategically
we are losing this war in every single way because we are worse
off right now than we were prior to the war. And now we're trying
to negotiate for pre-war conditions. Anytime you're trying to
negotiate for pre-war conditions, you lost the war. That's a
very interesting
So, why doesn't why doesn't America just nuke the hell out of
them? Um [snorts] so, if
Goo- good question.
>> If the United States If the United States nuked Iran,
this is what would
Uh I think Byron's going to get this
They nuked Iran.
I think there would be sanctions that the US couldn't like negotiate
their way out of, but we'll see. >> up the entire Gulf.
They'd destroy the desalination plants plants all across the
Gulf. Now, in the in the Gulf, uh desalination plant
Maybe. I think I think it'd be very hard. I think they've got
enough. [snorts] Maybe. Maybe they could do it. >> That's basically
what they do is they take the salt water and make it, you know,
potable and drink drinkable. >> Certainly this right here.
>> it's in the desert and that's where all their water
comes from. If you destroy power plants and desalination plants,
we're talking about a humanitarian crisis where 50 million people
live in the region. And these are all our allies, Qatar, Bahrain,
UAE, etc. So, if we were to nuke Iran, they would destroy the
Gulf completely. And we're talking about a humanitarian crisis
and energy crisis. It would be very bad. That's why Trump has
been very reluctant to bomb their power plants like he says he
wants because he knows that if he bombs those power plants, Iran
is going to retaliate by destroying the Gulf. Saudi Arabia, Bahrain,
UAE, all these countries rely on us for protection, which we
can't protect them right now. All of our bases are destroyed
and they're going to destroy Tel Aviv.
So, if we nuke them,
say goodbye to the entire region pretty much in the Gulf and
say goodbye to >> Well, some guy in my chat I don't think
they have the capacity to destroy Tel Aviv. I think I think they
would be doing that basically if they had the capacity to. I
think that was That's a crazy thing to add in at the end. Maybe
they could target desalination facilities. Maybe. >> Trump
is about to nuke. He addressed it this morning. Uh he did make
a tweet saying that they're going to hit the power plants and
stuff like that. But if he does that, he said that he's going
to hit the power plants if they don't do a deal. But I'll tell
you, dude, if he if he goes ahead and he hits the power plants
or destroys their bridges, the Gulf is done, dude. The Gulf is
done. It's cooked. Dude, I need to I need to get more into politics,
bro.
And and I'll tell you this, too.
the other thing with Trump, right? Is that he posts on Truth
Social? And what he does is he does this to like kind of um How
do you say that like he's missing out on a video game? Like he
just heard about a really cool gotcha game that's that he's missing
out on. Bro, I got to get into politics, dude. Oh my god. He's
really concerned with the markets. And a barrel of oil right
now, let me look a barrel of Brent crude is sitting at
because that's like really anytime
the price of oil goes up to okay so a barrel of Brent right now
sitting at about $92 which is still very high dude anything over
80 bucks is really What's what's WTI? 95.9
I guess 98 it was 90
slipping I'm slipping not very close really bad so
we got to a high of like 140 You don't think 750 missiles to
Iran at once would do that especially after they depleted they
their depleted interceptors? No
one it would it wouldn't do that but also Iran is down platforms
right now. Iran only has their like hidden underground platforms.
They cannot launch enough of a barrage of missiles without getting
hit like they will get hit pretty quickly launching from there
and you have to take time to move missiles in and out to actually
launch them right? They don't have the ability to fire 750 missiles
at once. You can't just launch these things off the sand.
You need a firm solid platform to launch them off of and they
only have so many that are remotely hidden and haven't been hit.
Their capacity to launch like a ton of missiles at the same time
is severely
150 per barrel dude we're talking about people's gas prices doubling
and when gas prices double everything else goes up alongside
it price of food price of energy you know like the economy suffers
and the thing is is that that's the short term
I will say
in the meantime
sorry not in the meantime in like as I'm listening to this or
watching this I'm looking at Tech Don's chat and they all think
Myron's wrong. Myron's 100% right on the energy stuff and that
like if there's a severe escalation against Iran they can hamper
the region even further and cause prices to soar on everything.
And so it's a little crazy to me that they are
that this chat doubts all of this >> So like if we were
to actually nuke
they would destroy all the oil infrastructure all across the
region and that would put the world in a global panic. Like it
would literally be on this said, "Iran can't handle the
They can't >> We already have the worst energy crisis ever
and things aren't even really destroyed yet like that. >> what
do you think's going to happen then? As far as like uh like completely?
Like the the my total Yeah, so like so so Trump's What happens
when all of the oil is made in the US? Not even cool.
If what If he doesn't nuke them? >> If he does like so
yeah, so if he doesn't nuke them, what do you think's going to
happen with Iran and America? So to be honest, dude, the US is
going to have to concede on some stuff. If if we actually want
to have like a diplomatic end to this where we can like have
some semblance of like, you know, affordable cuz here's the thing
that people don't understand. The American public is who's going
to suffer from this. When gas when when the when the cost of
a barrel of oil hits $100 plus, everyone's going to feel that
because your gas prices go up and then your food costs go up
and everything else goes up alongside of energy prices energy
and everything else. And here's another thing too that no one's
talking about. Iran has been making money because guess what?
We lifted the sanctions off Russia and off Iran. So the very
country who are fighting a war against that we sanctioned into
[__] hell, like we've lifted sanctions that people
could buy their oil now.
Also, before the before the blockade, Iran was still bringing
in everything they needed except it was all like black market
and basically the IRGC controls all of the [__] that
comes in on a on a black market rather than like straight over
like by the books. And so the IRGC was making money hand over
fist. The IRGC has probably never made more money than they did
in the first like three to four weeks of this war.
Like in terms of what just goes directly to the IRGC and not
any other faction there, it was crazy. >> money. Like like
it's like we've completely strengthened our enemies. We could
strengthen China, we strengthened Russia, we strengthened Iran
in this war despite the fact that we destroyed a lot of their
infrastructure. But um I think if we want to have have type of
amicable end to this where the world doesn't end and like we're
not like, you know, paying $10 for uh you know, a gallon of oil.
Um, we need to come up with some kind of diplomatic solution
and work with the Iranians and like stop letting the Israelis
dictate our foreign policy because the the Israelis are sabotaging
a lot of the diplomacy. Like they're still bombing in Lebanon
when there's supposed to be a ceasefire. They're Shut up. I'm
so uneducated on this topic.
>> It's all good, man. Like And that's And that's fair,
bro. Like Like And I really appreciate you allowing me to kind
of explain this because this is a very hot-button topic that
a lot of people don't like to talk
Like And I really appreciate you allowing me to kind of Hold
on. Putin gas has already been up with Biden already. Oh god,
no.
Oh no, I think I recognize this guy's name, too.
At least some I feel like there's somebody who's been in this
chat called Magnum Force. I Please, no. This is a very hot-button
topic that a lot of people don't like to talk about because it
makes a lot of people uncomfortable
um, in order to talk about this topic, you have to understand
power in America and it's a That's a very taboo topic that a
lot of streamers don't want to discuss cuz it'll get you banned.
For me, I I don't really give a [__] what anybody
ever talks about. I'm I'm down to have a discussion about everything.
For me, I think about life is all about hearing other people's
point of view, so I don't I don't I don't care. I I think it's
interesting. I like knowing how people feel and why they feel
I'm at least glad that you were able to say I feel this way because
rather than I feel this way. >> Yeah, and like And I'm
looking at people in your chat, right? And like they're like,
"Oh, this is off, whatever." Like prove what I said is wrong.
Like nobody can prove what I said is wrong. Like literally we're
in the middle of the worst energy crisis ever. Gas prices are
going up before the the world Dude, I'm sorry I have to keep
going. Iran has broken all their promises and attacked their
own allies. If Iran has a nuke, they'd end the world. I'd rather
$10 gas than us all be corpses. There really are humans like
this.
I This is like I swear there there may be no
more black-pilling
experience for democracy than watching a Tech Tone stream with
the chat
Like I
I I I I I I I I I I I I Like nobody can prove what I said is
wrong. Like literally we're in the middle of the worst energy
crisis ever. Gas prices are going up before the the war started,
a barrel of oil was like 60 to 50 bucks, right? Strategically
we are losing this war. And like every war analyst actually agrees
with me. If you look at like someone like um like experts um
Robert Pape, John Mearsheimer, Colonel Douglas McGregor, like
anyone that understands, you know, conflict, like anyone that
has any type of real geopolitical awareness understands that
this conflict is a major L for the United States. So, you know,
and the only people that don't understand that are like that
watch Fox News every day. They don't understand geopolitical
affairs because most Americans are stupid. Let's be honest. Like
they don't they don't know where anything is on a map. They don't
understand Middle Eastern foreign policy. They don't really know
who really runs this country. And that's fine. I get it. But
I love like I'm looking at some of the people in your chat. It's
like prove me wrong. None of you guys can prove me >> Yeah, I
even heard that some Americans don't even know when World War
II was.
No, they don't, dude. They don't. They don't know what the Balfour
Declaration is. They can't point Israel on a map. Like you know
what I mean? It's like and I've debated [laughter] Zionists on
this, too. I did a debate with Dinesh D'Souza. I absolutely cooked
him on this topic. Like cuz he couldn't The defense of Israel
is an indefensible position. We have we get zero strategic benefit
from aligning from Israel. And this is why Zionists are terrified
to talk to people like me, Nick Fuentes.
Oh, no, I'm not making fun of Mearsheimer for being wrong. I
think I think the analysis he gave is solid. I understand people
don't like the Russia the the Russia-Ukraine analysis he gave,
And that's fine. I don't really know the underlying details there
that well. But I do know the underlying details here fairly well,
and I do think the analysis he gave is pretty good. I wasn't
mocking Mearsheimer there. >> etc. cuz once you understand
this stuff and you know what it is, it's like an indefensible
position. Like there's no benefit to supporting Israel at all.
It puts us in a very bad spot.